- [Interviewer] Let's
say you guys break up
as couples will do.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You
get all your money back
or he takes the money?
- No, no.
I mean, I'm the bitch.
So therefore everything still go to him.
Probably even when I'm not his bitch,
I'm still his bitch, so.
- [Interviewer] All right,
Mariah, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up originally?
- I grew up in Chicago, Illinois.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You had both of your parents
when you were growing up?
- Yeah, I grew up with my parents.
They were separated,
but I still have both of them in my life.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- Actually, I grew up, I had
a good, spoiled childhood.
An interesting childhood, but.
- [Interviewer] In what ways?
- I lived the,
the normal childhood life,
getting everything I wanted.
Spoiled, I guess that's why
I'm a brat now (chuckles).
- [Interviewer] But like
any traumatic events
in your childhood, any abuse,
anything like that?
- Well, when I was younger,
I was kinda like molested when
I was younger, growing up.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was around 12.
- [Interviewer] And who did this?
- It was actually with one
of my mom's boyfriends.
- [Interviewer] Did you say anything?
- At the time, no, I didn't.
But over the years as it went by,
then that's when I actually
start seeing things about it.
- [Interviewer] So it continued
for a longer period of time?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Did
you ever catch the guy?
- Over the years, I still see him around.
Every now and then I still see him around.
But
I really don't say much to him.
But I have confronted him about it.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Say what?
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Oh my gosh.
I was
an outgoing kid.
I
did a lot of sports.
Volleyball, basketball.
- [Interviewer] You were popular?
You had friends?
- No, I was not the
popular type in school.
I was more of the loner.
The loner, didn't get
along well with others.
Stayed in my own lane.
Quiet.
I was quiet.
Didn't hang around the
big crowds. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] And then
you left home at what age?
- I left home, I moved home when I was 16.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you go?
- I moved to Atlanta.
I had ran away, moved to Atlanta.
I stayed in Atlanta from
about six years; six, seven years.
And then from Atlanta I came here.
- [Interviewer] So did
you finished high school?
- No.
- You didn't?
- [Interviewer] And what were you doing?
- I dropped out like in the 11th grade.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how are
you supporting yourself then?
- At that time?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I started prostitutin',
getting into the big
that type of life and
everything like that.
And
had a pimp.
And that's how I survived.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And today you're working with
a pimp or you're on your own?
- No, always worked with a pimp.
Always like had someone with me out there.
- [Interviewer] Including today?
- Yes, always.
- [Interviewer] And what's the advantage
of working with a pimp for you?
'Cause I hear many of the girls say,
"Hell no, I would never do that.
"Why give him my money?"
- I mean,
it's for each his own, you know?
Protection, keep you stabilized,
everything like that.
- [Interviewer] And your relationship
with your pimp is good, do you like?
- It's open, yes.
It's different for each his own.
You know, it's open.
You know, I'm an open
book myself, so it's open.
- [Interviewer] But he treats you well?
- Every relationship has problems.
The fights, the black eyes,
you don't make the money.
It's consequence.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So do you have children?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Never married?
- [Interviewer] You're young.
How old are you?
- I'm 28.
- [Interviewer] You're 28.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] So when
you decided to move
from Atlanta to L.A.,
you went with your pimp
or you went on your own and relocated?
- No, when I first went to
Atlanta, I went by myself.
- - [Interviewer] And then when you came
from Atlanta to L.A.?
- Then when I came from
L.A., I mean to Atlanta, to
here already had my pimp by then.
I met him out there.
- [Interviewer] And he
came with you out here?
- Mm-hmm.
- I see.
- [Interviewer] You ever been arrested?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Never?
- [Interviewer] You've had
rough experiences doing this?
- I've been robbed.
Been jumped on a few times.
And that's when he's not around,
from people where different
other girls set you up.
So yes.
- [Interviewer] So it's a rough life.
- It's definitely a rough life
and I don't encourage nobody
to get into it because it's
it's
it's a choice, but it's also life.
Sometimes it's that's experience
we have to go through at times.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think there's anything
in your childhood that kind
of paved the way for this
to happen for you?
The child abuse or the way?
- No.
To be honest, I never expected this.
I never expected to
be prostitutin' or none of
the things that I was doing.
I never expected it.
I never expected that at all.
- [Interviewer] Did you have dreams
of doing anything else as a kid?
- No.
Actually my dream as a kid,
I wanted to be a streetwalker (chuckles).
- [Interviewer] So you
made your dreams come true?
- (Laughing) Kind of, huh?
- [Interviewer] So why would a young girl
dream about something like that?
What is it about your,
the way you grew up that made you think
that that was something that you wanted?
- Because I always wanted to do porn then.
Growing up young I used
to want to do porn.
- [Interviewer] At what age
did you have these thoughts?
- I was like 14, 15.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's interesting
that at such a young age
you aspired to doing
sex work.
- Yes.
- I really that's,
I wanted to go into that field
but I guess me being so
nervous about being on camera
I don't think I would've did it, so.
- [Interviewer] So you never did that.
- No, and I probably
still wouldn't (laughing).
- [Interviewer] So do you make good money
working the street?
- Oh yeah, good money.
I can come in, I don't
want to say how much
I actually come in with.
'Cause it's just for safety reasons.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah.
But you make good money.
- Oh yes, definitely good money.
- [Interviewer] And are drugs
a part of the picture for you?
- No, no drugs, no drugs.
Just never got into the
drug thing, you know?
- [Interviewer] That's rare.
- Yeah, it's very rare.
Like I said, my man keeps
me kind of (tongue clicking)
off of a lot of them things.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
Do you recall your first time,
the first trick you picked up?
- (Tongue clicks) Oh, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
You wanna hear about it?
- [Interviewer] I do.
- Actually, my first one.
His name was Rob, actually.
- [Interviewer] This is Atlanta?
- Hmm?
- [Interviewer] This
is Atlanta or Chicago?
- This was in Chicago.
- Chicago.
- I started in Chicago and
worked my way to Atlanta.
But my very first time.
- [Interviewer] And you were how old?
- I was around 16.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- 16 at that time.
And it had to been around like April.
And I was walking home from school.
And the car pulled up on me
and everything like that.
Actually, I was ditching.
And I was supposed to been at school,
taking my lunch break, but ditching.
And didn't never go back
'cause I went with him.
But he wound up approaching
me, asking me what was my name?
And then asked me, was I hungry?
How old was I,
show me his penis.
It was kind of a turn on at the time.
- [Interviewer] He did that
to prove that he's not a cop, or?
- Yeah, he kinda did that to
prove that he wasn't a cop.
- [Interviewer] That's how the guys,
that's how the guys prove
that they're not cops?
- Yeah.
And then he asked me to show a titty
because he wants to make sure that
I didn't get him in trouble
and everything like that.
So I did that.
Then we discussed the price.
I wouldn't have jumped
in the car with him.
And we left and I actually
stayed gone with him
for like three days, for like three days.
- [Interviewer] And
typically you'll do business
in a hotel, motel, or a car, or wherever?
- Hotel, motel, car, alley, the streets.
- [Interviewer] Wherever.
- Wherever.
- [Interviewer] And you
practice safe sex, I assume?
- Always.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] And the guys will want,
what kind of sexual interaction?
- All kinds,
all kinds.
It's really no limits
of, no limits with them.
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest request you've had?
I've heard some of the
girls tell me crazy stuff.
- Yes.
I have mens
that
wants you to like
urinate on them,
urinate in their mouth.
They have
anal fetishes,
feet fetishes,
where they pay like extreme amount, so.
But I think the most
one that got me is when
the men asked me to
like poop in his mouth.
That was like (laughing) you know?
That one right there was
just like a lot for me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
so you've been around.
You've heard all the crazy requests.
- Oh, yes, yes.
- [Interviewer] So your
pimp keeps all your money?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] But the
reason you're okay with that
is he's gonna manage that money and
help you do what?
- To a certain extent.
It helps me out.
It helps us out.
But we're still in a
relationship too, so it's like.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
But let's say you guys break
up, as couples will do.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Then you
get all your money back
or he takes the money?
- No, no.
I mean, I'm the bitch.
So therefore everything's still go to him.
Probably even when I'm not his bitch,
I'm still his bitch.
So it's consequences.
- [Interviewer] And that thinking,
I'm sure it will become a source of
a lot of comments on this video.
What is it about your childhood
made you believe that that's an okay way
to interact with a male?
That giving him all your,
you're working you're risking your life
and your health and all
kinds of self-esteem issues.
You're giving the pimp all your money.
And if anything goes sour,
he runs off with the money
and you're left with what?
Nothing.
- Nothin'.
- [Interviewer] And
you're okay with all that?
- You have no choice.
You either gonna to deal
with it or you're not.
Or when he see you out there,
they beat you and take it from you.
So you're either ass if
you do or ass if you don't.
- [Interviewer] Right.
And if you were to go out on your own,
or if you told him you're
gonna go renegade at one point,
how would that conversation go?
- Most of the time he's around,
but they still go off
and do they own thing.
But they still be around.
They make they rounds.
- [Interviewer] So if
you were on your own,
a renegade as they call it,
you'd still have to give
away your money you think?
- Hmm, good question.
Good question.
Well, I don't know because
I still know other girls
that don't have pimps
or nothing like that.
And they still giving out their money
and still getting beat up by people.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Yeah, it's a tough.
- So it's, I guess,
it's about the strong ones.
Only the strong will survive.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What, what personality trait do you have
that helps you helps you do this,
helps you survive?
- Prayer.
That's about it.
Prayer helped me survive everything.
Even though I do what I do,
it still helps me survive.
And getting out there,
doing what I need to do.
- [Interviewer] Does it
get you down sometimes?
- Of course.
- [Interviewer] You're depressed?
I mean, everybody does.
- Mm-hmm, everybody have depressed days.
- [Interviewer] You're in
Starbucks, you get depressed.
But there's certain things about
this line of work that can
make you feel like you are.
- Yeah, but see you got to know how to
cut the depression off.
You gotta know how to cut
all that off and live.
We go through a lot from
being raped out here
to being abused,
even at home, or anywhere else.
So you got to really have
some tough skin out here.
You got to really have some tough skin.
- [Interviewer] Does your
family know you're doing this?
- No (chuckles).
No, my family don't know what I do.
They,
actually I ran away
and left my family years ago kind of.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
have contact with them?
- Every blue moon I contact them.
I haven't really talked to
them in like three, four years.
Like kinda went M.I.A.
- [Interviewer] Were there
things going on at home
that made you run away at 16,
and now not have contact with your family?
- Yes, lot of problems.
Lots of problems at home.
So I just went on and left home.
And I left, like I said, I left at 16
and moved to Atlanta
and I never went back.
Never went back.
- [Interviewer] What do you think the most
misunderstood thing about this lifestyle?
Like the people that don't
do it don't understand it.
They'll hear your story and go,
"But that's crazy.
"Why would a girl ever do that?"
- Sometimes you put in a predicament,
we all have choices but sometimes,
you have to take another path
to get what you need at times.
And how else can I explain that?
- [Interviewer] The
options that you had at 16.
- It's not really too many
options when you're young.
You have so many, you have
options, but not many.
So when you get hungry,
you don't have a shelter over your head,
you don't have nobody but yourself.
And then yeah, a lot of people
are looking and be like,
well why still turn to that?
You wouldn't know.
When you have absolutely nothing,
nothing, and you did pray,
and you have tried to come
up with different solutions,
and you came up with that
solution and it works.
You stick with what was
working for you at that time.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever
find yourself doing things other
than trading sex for money?
Are you sometimes maybe
getting the guy's watch or is?
- No, I'm honest with them.
I don't rob my Does or anything like that.
I like to keep it straight,
100 with them because
I don't want to get them hurt.
And then I wouldn't want to
put myself in that predicament.
Because every car I jump in
is definitely a 95% chance
that I'm never probably
can come back again.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What was the best time of your life?
When were you happiest?
- When I was a kid.
- [Interviewer] Younger?
- Yeah, 16 on down.
And it was like the best times of my life.
- [Interviewer] And when was the worst?
- This.
- [Interviewer] Right now?
- Corona.
- [Interviewer] Yeah (laughing).
It's hard to make money for a girl, right?
- No, the pandemic is easy.
This is easy money out
here with the pandemic.
It's just,
the
deaths.
That's how I can say it, all the deaths.
Sad news.
- [Interviewer] Do you know
people that know people
that have died?
- No.
Just the hearing about it
and things like that.
- Yeah, it's scary.
- The stories, it's very stressful, so.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you're addicted
to this lifestyle?
Do you think getting
out would be difficult?
- Good question.
- [Interviewer] Just telling your pimp,
you know what, you're
going to quit next week
and you're gonna get a job at Nordstrom.
- No, that's not gonna happen.
(Chuckles).
- I'm in it to win it.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever stand back
and just look at your life and go,
man, this is just nuts
that I'm doing this?
It's crazy?
Because it is a crazy lifestyle.
- No, not yet.
- [Interviewer] No?
- Maybe because I'm enjoying
it so much right now.
- [Interviewer] You're still enjoying it.
- Still enjoying it.
I'm young.
Why not?
- [Interviewer] It's exciting?
- (Laughing) Oh, it's different.
It's different.
Very different.
Hell, it's sex everyday.
Today, millennials loves sex.
I get best of both worlds.
Money and sex.
- [Interviewer] You been in love before?
- No, I'm not in love.
I say, "Fuck love."
- [Interviewer] You're makin' money.
- Make money.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] I'm so glad we met.
- Glad to meet you too.
- [Interviewer] Good luck out there.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] All right, Mariah.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Thanks.